[Music]
foreign
politano here for judging Freedom today
is Tuesday November 29
2022 it's about five o'clock in the
afternoon here on the east coast of the
United States three o'clock in the
afternoon in sunny California where my
next guest who of course is no stranger
to the show or to any of you watching us
it's coming from Dr Joel Wallach of
course is the Premier naturopathic
physician in the United States today
whose life has been devoted to showing
people how they can stay healthy get
healthy stay healthy live better live
longer using natural solutions rather
than anything artificial or prescribed
by an MD uh Dr Wallach always a pleasure
welcome back to judging freedom well
it's an honor to be with you honorable
Judge and McKenna thank you enough for
the opportunity to share this
information with you and Gary and the
whole world well everybody that watches
us is giving great reviews to the
explanations you're giving today I know
you want to talk about
longevity living longer exercise and
what you need to do to live longer so
I'll with that introduction I'll put the
ball in your court
and let you run with it okay your honor
thank you so very much okay well there's
a lot of misinformation out there and I
deal with professional athletes Olympic
athletes University athletes we've taken
people like Theo Ratliff who is a famous
basketball player at age 24 you know in
Georgia he's playing for the Atlanta
Hawks and uh he had a 35 million dollar
contract at 24 years of age had bone
bone arthritis in both knees he
currently popped off his hip he
fractured a shooting arm wrist in his
right hand and they took his contract
away from him make a long story short
um
Pastor Creflo Dollar from down there in
Georgia introduced me to Theo I came up
with our
um healthy Bone and Joint pack for him
we created it for him and um he came
back three months later after we rebuilt
him and he played for 11 years made 100
million dollars in contracts on our
program so you think he likes our
product absolutely and then there's
another one Evander Holyfield great
heavyweight champion and he had a heart
attack I never fatal heart attack in
defense when he was defending his title
against Michael Moore and he couldn't
answer the last Bell so he lost his
title by default because he couldn't
answer the bill we came up with a
healthy Brandon hard pack for him and
six months later he came back and he
just smashed
um let's see here let's see here who was
it uh
Mike Tyson Mike Tyson he's he just
smashed him so badly the referee stopped
in the sixth round because his arms were
down and Evander holy was just pounding
him he was going to kill him if this
referee didn't stop it
okay he got his title back now who comes
back from a near a fatal heart attack to
win a heavyweight championship fight
against Mike Tyson you got to be kidding
me okay and so this is what we do
now let's look at life expectancies of
professional athletes because this is
who we deal with professional athletes
Olympic athletes University athletes of
all kinds and so when you look at the
life expectancy okay of
professional athletes in America this is
America alone it ranges according to the
government U.S government from 53 to 59.
hmm okay
um that's that's our life expectancy for
professional athletes in America well
that seems awfully low okay 53-59
and we're gonna we're gonna tell you why
in a moment there's a reason for it okay
there's a reason for it remember I'm a
pathologist I I got a 25 million dollar
Grant from NIH I did 20 000 autopsies
I I know pathology very well my thesis
is in the Smithsonian Institute the
national treasurer and so anyway
um the life expectancy as I said of of
professional athletes when you combine
all sports is 53 to 59 uh the general
average if you want to pick one figure
is 56.7 okay and then
um when you're looking at Young athletes
are in the prime of their career 25
years and younger each year in America
Alone 2 000 die under the age of 25
suddenly from hypertrophy cardiomyopathy
heart disease it's actually the same
disease as sediment death syndrome which
occurs in kids under the age of 10. I'm
the guy who figured that out I figured
out both of them and we came up with we
beat the FDA in federal court nine times
but Jonathan anymore you may know my
attorney John's anymore
um
hi and we we beat the FDA in federal
court nine times we had these minerals
put into Enfamil and Similac and within
90 days we ended sentiment death
syndrome we ended most recently we ended
physiobrosis by putting these nutrients
into the baby formulas which doctors
have kept stopping from from happening
okay then billionaires the average
lifespan in America for billionaires is
66 according to the U.S government ER
doctors emergency room doctors their
life expectancy is 58.7 not very good
record for our systems
okay so what's going on here what is
going on here well I have three CDs I'll
send you that set okay I'll send you the
set
judge
um and so there'll be something we'll
take care of we will send you the set
but we want everybody that's that what
what will it explain what will it take
okay
CD number one is dead athletes don't lie
it goes along with the book Dead Doctors
Don't Lie
I've done so many autopsies on dead
athletes and we figured out why they
died and so forth what's going on and
again it's a it's a nutritional
deficiencies why they died
okay CD number two exercise without
supplementation is suicide
now there's so many doctors and so many
coaches that say just exercise don't
waste your money on violence middle just
exercise and eat well you get everything
you need well exercise without
supplementation is suicide
remember the
the
um life expectancy for professional
athletes is 53 to 59 and under 25 years
of age every year in America 2 000 die
from
um hypertrophy cardiom heart disease
2000 is crazy well how does a 25 year
old athlete get heart disease what
causes it it's a nutritional deficiency
I'm going to get to that just a little
bit more before I get to the to the kill
Point here okay and then to CD number
three is what kills billionaires I put
it in there for two reasons they have
all the money in the world they can
afford to buy the best of the best of
the best food they go out for dinner
they spend 100 bucks a piece for meals
and so on they have the best doctors
what they say
and their average life expectancy in
America is
um 50 excuse me 66 66. not good okay and
so those three CDs dead athletes don't
lie exercise on supplementation of
suicide what kills billionaires all
right and so it's one of those things
where
um information is powerful okay because
when you do the autopsies and all these
dead famous people the athletes okay and
the billionaires
they have all these changes in their
body to tell you what they were missing
why they died and of course uh there's
you know 50 different ways they could
die from an artificial deficiency
ruptured aneurysms
um
they get
um liver cirrhosis the heart disease
they get lung disease
you know all these things
um because they're they're they can't
even absorb nutrition because they're
eating gluten they're eating Wheat by
the round notes and the doctors say oh
eat more whole grains and so they eat
wheat Brown around oats it kills their
lining their intestines so instead of
looking like a shag rug with all the
Villi and the little finger-like
projections now their intestines are
eating gluten and buckwheat their
intestines look like a plastic tube
they've lost 90 percent of their
absorptive surface so even if I had one
today on my radio shows a lady called up
she was 90 years old she's taking all
these nutrients and she's I'm not
getting any benefit
I said what do you have for breakfast
every morning well I have toast well
wheat toast for breakfast every morning
if it's gluten killing your intestines
at 90 years old that's why you can't
absorb the nutrition that's why you're
not getting any benefit
it's very simple stuff okay so
um
and think that covers the thing people
can go to our uh to you to get this
information I'm going to send you those
three sets so you know Becca is going to
package them up and we'll send them to
you uh dead athletes don't lie exercises
on someone say suicide and there's an
enormous amount of information here I
mean we did a lot of of effort of going
through uh obituaries of of athletes and
so this isn't stuff we're just making up
this is based on a lot of science heavy
duty science and being a pathologist I
can read the dead body better than most
people okay what what does uh exercise
do for longevity
um exercise can tone up your muscles
okay
um can
um help you with Hunger okay it makes
you hungry so you'll eat food and so
forth
it may support your immune system a
little bit
but exercise I mean if you just lay in a
bed and get intravenous all the
nutrition you need all the good stuff
you need
um if everything would be perfect you
would not need to exercise
okay you don't need exercise exercise is
required to chase down the Buffalo
you're gonna you know throw a spear at
or shoot them or something like that and
so uh you need to be in good shape to be
able to to chase down food or work your
farm well exercise really isn't
necessary
okay because we take animals laboratory
animals we put them in a little cage so
they can't move and we give them all the
nutrients and they live longer than all
the the little animals on the wheel
doing all the exercise on the wheel and
the exercise wheel for the round so I'm
I'm surprised to hear you say exercise
isn't necessary you may be the only
health care provider I've ever heard of
say that obviously I have great respect
for your career and your work but
doesn't exercise help the body
strengthen the muscles strengthen the
lungs it can tone up they can tone up
the muscle as I said earlier it'll do
things like toning up the muscles and
that kind of stuff but exercise doesn't
add years to your life
um
and so all this stuff with these
professional athletes show that very
clearly okay this is unimpeachable
evidence this is evidence collected by
the U.S Public Health Department uh
University uh sports teams and so forth
professional sports team and I'm just
reporting what they published okay I
didn't I didn't come up with this you
can't say well maybe my dad is wrong
this is no this is heavy duty stuff by
people who have access to all this
information
and so I exercise I walk three miles a
day
okay I don't do it one time I welcome
aisle and I do a lot of radio and stuff
like that like I've walked two miles
already this morning and when we're done
um and a half hour uh a little snack or
something like that and then I'll walk
another mile I walk three miles a day
I've been doing it for over 50 years I
lettered in football and wrestling in in
high school and University
um
um you know why do you walk three miles
a day Dr Wallach
uh because it's boring just sitting in a
chair no
well doesn't it make you stronger
doesn't it help your posture doesn't it
help your breathing doesn't it help your
sleep it tones up your muscles it tones
up your muscles I don't need exercise to
sleep okay just eat a big meal and get
sleepy
okay
um but no exercise is fine as long as
you're getting all the nutrients if
you're exercising you're not getting the
nutrients you're sweating out the
nutrients see this is what was going on
with the Vander Holyfield and Theo
Ratliff they're sweating out all these
nutrients faster than they were taking
them in
and when we gave them these nutritional
programs they were designed for athletes
I mean in months
we rebuilt everything and their careers
were over I mean they were just inches
away from dying okay and we rebuilt them
they came back and beat you know like
Evander Holyfield beat Mike Tyson you
got to be kidding me and Phil Ratliff
came back and played for 11 more years
in professional basketball all right so
if someone wants to know what Basics to
take in order to enhance longevity they
can get them from judginghealth.com
because that's where you have that's
where we have your Basics that's correct
and what are those Basics that people
should be looking for okay they need the
90th Century nutrients minimum that's
our Healthy Start package 16 minerals 16
vitamins 12 ameos and Three fatty acids
and it covers all of the body's needs
for all of the things that goes on in
the body
okay every organ requires all these
nutrients
okay then we also have what we call the
healthy abandoned heart pack which has
215 nutrients
including that core 90 essential
nutrients and then we have we call
secret sauces now this is a secret okay
it's one of those things the secret
sauces
for instance if you have problems with
your lungs in addition to the healthy
brand and heart pack and stay away from
all the bad foods we would have you take
our oxy body which is a source of oxygen
it's a liquid source of oxygen okay and
also we have
um
the ability to get rid of asthma we can
get rid of animals just in days and
weeks it's very easy to get rid of it's
a nutritional deficiency asthma is it's
not a genetic thing or autoimmune thing
okay so we can get rid of asthma very
easily and then
um the same way with
um heart disease there's all kinds of
heart disease there's again
um the let's see here you had
cardiopathy heart disease which is a
sudden medicinal Roman kids under age of
10 it's the
um let's see here cardio
myopathy in in teenagers and adults okay
cardiomyopathy okay and I I can rebuild
their heart in weeks what what is what
is cardiomyopathy okay cardiomyopathy is
a
um where the heart muscle turns into
just like connective tissue the heart
muscle goes away and is dying
okay and Keyshawn promised China they
call it kishan disease okay
um Dr Milani we went there we went to
Keyshawn University in Helen Jong
Province we did 1 700 autopsy on kids
under the age attempt
it was a huge project and won many
awards including the Lifetime
Achievement Award from the United
Nations for that we showed that these
diseases were not genetic they're not
armune they're just a simple nutritional
efficiency you take the nutrients and we
can reverse those diseases in weeks and
nobody has to die
and um the heart disease is very simple
stuff
um these there's coronary artery disease
which is totally different from the
cardiomyopathy uh in coronary artery
disease is caused by eating
foods that oxidize and turn into trans
fats ketocyclominees acrylamides and
cause inflammation which cause your
arteries in your brain and your heart
and your kidneys to try and defend
themselves was connective tissue scar
tissue and this your own Scar Tissue
that's blocking the arteries it's not
cholesterol cholesterol makes up 25 of
your brain weight and 25 percent of your
spinal cord weight what what foods what
foods should people stay away from Dr
Wallach fried foods
of all kinds nothing fried no processed
Meats because a lot of chemicals in them
you know including bacon and ham and
sausage and bologna and salami and that
kind of stuff they need to stay away
from wheat panoranos and buckwheat those
grains no wheat Brown oats and buckwheat
then you stay away from them to stay
away from the gluten and the
phagopyrenes which kill your intestines
so you cannot absorb food what about
sugar
sugar again a little bit of sugar is
fine and of course you look at Red Bull
uh that was a major part of that product
was um sugar
and um
let's see here
um sugar was a big big part of it and
and also caffeine was a big part of it
it was an energy drink it was not a
nutritional drink it was an energy drink
each year they sell this chart of 8
billion 8 billion cans of Red Bull and
so my new thing now uh your honor is I
say there's a new Bull in town that's me
I'm a new bowling town okay we have our
rebound our sports drink okay we have a
hundred nutrients in here we have 75
minerals in our rebound we have 75
minerals and a rebound and Red Bull has
one red bull only has magnesium in it we
have 75 minerals and 25 vitamins amino
acids comes in cans
it comes in canisters with 36 servings
in there
well that's the one I take I take the
powdered one each morning that I mix
with water and fruit juice yeah that's
perfect very good way to do it and then
of course we have the sticks when I go
on the road someplace you know we're
driving I'll take maybe three or four of
these six with me there's 30 of these
sticks in a box
I take two or three or four of these
sticks with me and put in my pocket and
so if I you know want a little bit of
energy and I'm going to miss a meal or
something I'll have the rebound sticks
with me I just stick them in a bottle of
water okay and so okay and so our new
advertising program
uh is it's like there's a new sheriff in
town There's a new Bull in town okay and
that's me and our rebound you're saying
this because the owner of Red Bull who
boasted about all of his own product
that he drank recently died at an age
younger than you are yeah he died at 78
and he said he had some chronic disease
he I haven't seen anything or said when
he died from it he just said he died of
a chronic disease that he had and so I'm
still waiting for something to come out
the the full story of what he died from
and I'm sure they're kind of trying to
find some way to say
you know it wasn't the product or it
wasn't lacking something because he was
taking so much of the product and so on
all right
it's always a pleasure no matter what
we're talking about just to remind
everybody they can purchase these
products at judginghealth.com
which is our partnership judging
Freedom's partnership with youngevity
and it gets your right to their uh
website and if you don't understand
anything on the website there's plenty
of folks on the other side of that 800
number that will help you uh understand
it Dr Wallach always a pleasure my dear
friend
well your honor is an honored to be with
you and your in your your Sidekick Gary
you you do a great job in getting
information out to the public and that's
what it takes information is life-saving
information life-saving I can't thank
you enough for letting us participate
with you thank you sir we'll talk to you
again next week thank you very much
judgment politano for judging freedom
[Music]
thank you